foreign
s which are the ants bees and wasps as
you know are often highly social there
are some solitary species of
hymenopterans and that sociality is
driven in large part by the use
sociality that is Downstream of their
unusual genetics their haplodiploid
which uh in means that all of the
females are diploid just like we are we
have two copies of all of our
chromosomes but the males are haploid
they only have one copy and that has all
sorts of fascinating effects including
that for instance full sisters or three
quarters related to one another and
they're only half related to their
mothers and so
um so can selection Theory suggests
there are more likely to be interested
in the production of more sisters than
they are in reproducing on their own
which I'll just add is why the stinging
bees the uh stinging apparatus is
actually the ovipositor it's the egg
layer that has been modified into a
weapon because they don't need it as an
egg layer because they're better off
facilitating the reproduction of their
mother with full siblings
than they are of retaining the capacity
to reproduce themselves right
um now that you know that logic only
holds for full siblings for half
siblings they're a little bit less
related to their half siblings than they
would be three it's related to their
half siblings then they would be related
to their own
um children and that 3 8 is a
probability whereas they're they'd be
exactly half related to their own kids
um we can I'd I'd be happy to go on
endlessly about the genics of apple
diploidy and other time as I used to
with my students but this is not the
place
um although one of the other interesting
effects of the haploidiploid system in
hymenopterans again ants bees and wasps
is that males don't have sons males only
have daughters and sons therefore males
also don't have fathers they only have
um they only have mothers so all of that
is is which makes for kind of a fraught
relationship
yeah with whom between these fatherless
sons and their mothers who are wrongly
described as Queens but are really
slaves of the colony anyway it's not
fraud at all they're 100 related to
their moms right which
could be rough I don't know no no not
helpful
um so it's been long assumed that the
behaviors of the social insects were
innate genetic right not socially
learned but new research suggests uh
slightly otherwise so uh nope not yet
don't take my screen off while I scroll
to the top
um here okay now you can put my screen
back on
um this published
um I believe this week or at least very
recently in uh plus biology so this is
an Open Access Journal
um high quality Journal bumblebees
acquire alternative puzzle box Solutions
via social learning published by a
number of people out of Queen Mary
University of London
and I will just read first the
introduction and then the abstract and
then we'll talk about a little bit
or the first paragraph or so of the
introduction the diversity of behaviors
observed in some social in in some
insect societies is how par with or
exceeds that of some mammals and
includes the construction of
architecturally complex
climate-controlled nests and the
division of labor between foraging brood
care and Nest defense indeed outside the
human realm their nesting structures are
unparalleled in terms of their
regularity sophistication and their
scale and proportion to body size there
is profound variation in foraging
specializations architectures and social
organizations not just between related
species of social insects but more
intriguingly even within species
while these specializations have
historically been viewed as a limited
set of pre-programmed responses to
external stimuli resulting from
evolutionary trial and error processes
this innate repertoire is supplemented
by a remarkable capacity for learning
that has been recognized for decades the
acquisition of the honeybee dance
language is perhaps the best
characterized example of social learning
described thus far in an invertebrate
and as early as 1884 Darwin suggested
that nectar robbing of flowers by
bumblebees could spread socially I did
not remember that that Darwin had
suggested this then they've got
um what they actually did here is uh to
investigate social learning a two-act
action control experimental design is
helpful as this can help exclude
alternative explanations
such designs have been used to great
effect to investigate social learning
and chimpanzees with demonstrators
trained to obtain food from a pan pipes
apparatus in one of two different ways
and observers acquiring their
demonstrators technique
meanwhile without a demonstrator no
chimpanzees acquired either technique
so you seed you seed the culture of
chimpanzees with a way to solve a
problem and The Chimps pick up that way
to solve the problem but they don't
solve the problem at all when you don't
seed it at least in the experiment here
cited
um
meanwhile without a demonstrator more
recently in great tits demonstrators
were trained to open a puzzle box in one
of two possible ways before seeding them
back into wild populations
the demonstrator's preferences that's
Birds by the way great tits you knew
that I did yeah
um
the demonstrator's preferences spread
throughout these groups and were
maintained long term even when the
alternative Behavior was discovered and
even though the two variants were
entirely arbitrary
so interesting right two arbitrary
apparently equally good ways to solve a
problem when one or the other is seated
into a population that's the one that
spreads when when a demonstrator is fed
into a population and it Remains the
consistently preferred one even when
some other non-demonstrated birds uh
stumble across invent whatever learn the
other way of doing things their way
which is supposedly neither better nor
worse although that's going to be really
hard to actually obtain in in a real
world situation
um the the newly discovered way does not
end up winning the day
um
for the present study as you would
expect
my opinion yeah with the big caveat that
the two ways of doing things have to
really be equivalently good and that's
that's a for me that's it being people
you would expect that conservatism yep
uh for the present study we designed two
option puzzle box feeders that formed by
previous work in bumblebee problem
solving which replicated those used to
investigate the spread of arbitrary
behavioral differences in great tip
populations we then developed an open
diffusion protocol that allowed the
spread of box opening through the group
to be recorded and seated colonies of
bumblebees with demonstrators trained to
perform one of the two possible
behavioral variants these novel foraging
techniques were successfully acquired by
untrained bees via social learning and
there's a lot more to say here but uh as
as they allude to there in the
introduction which is uh
odd but they allude to the results in
the discussion there
um
they uh this pref box opening Behavior
spread through colonies seated with a
demonstrator trained to perform one of
the two possible behavioral variants and
The Observers acquired the demonstrated
variant this preference persisted among
observers even when the alternative
technique was discovered
and in control diffusion experiments
that lacked a demonstrator
some bees spontaneously open the puzzle
boxes but for significantly less
proficient than those that learn in the
presence of a demonstrator so much is
what has previously been described
discovered and described in both chimps
and great tits which are in turns mammal
and bird which are known to be uh you
know have complex brains highly social
highly capable of learning with cultural
transmission of information here we have
a very similar result in bumblebees now
these authors are not going so far as to
call this
um this evidence of culture because
bumblebees die out Bumblebees are
effectively annuals with only the queen
surviving overwintering and so you don't
have the acquisition of this learning
taking place multi-generationally but
you do have it within the season that
that it is happening and thus as the
authors say this is likely to be a
necessary precursor too if not um
sufficient to describe an organism as
having culture
yeah
frankly I find that distinction a little
arbitrary I get why it is they're using
a definition of culture that requires
cross-generational yeah um transmission
yeah and that is a real distinction yep
on the other hand all of the
capabilities here transmitting a
behavioral phenomenon like that across
the population uh I would say
a it raises questions because not all
hymenopterans are annuals
and therefore if the same capacity
existed in something like let's say
fetch ants yeah then you would expect it
to transmit you would expect a colony to
have this capacity and to transmit it
um through generations Generations being
a little bit of a weird term because
you've got presumably a single queen
although there are things that happen
when a queen
dies but anyway all that aside
the reason that you would expect
a group of bees who had learned a
technique from a demonstrator to be
resistant to the acquisition of a new
technique though equally good is that it
wouldn't be equally good because they
would be less proficient at the one they
hadn't practiced precisely and so you
would expect this resistance to doing it
the new way
and the real question is how much better
does the new way have to be than the old
way in order to overcome that
conservatism which then becomes a model
for exactly what we have in Civilization
where there's a tendency to want to do
things the way we've done them which is
the right tendency and then there is
sometimes a benefit that is worth
engaging in the changeover cost well and
I think here here is one of the places
where um so bumblebees being annuals and
humans decidedly not
will make the answer to that question
potentially very different right like if
you've got a colony that has a A month's
months long a lifespan measured in
months rather than a societal lifespan
that could possibly be measured in
Millennia or at least centuries it's a
very different analysis to say okay like
I don't care how many times you managed
to do the thing you're going to be dead
next month and it probably doesn't make
sense for you to learn a totally new
technique when what you're doing is
equally good or even
um just slightly less good and I will
say actually um that with regard to the
B work
um it was like
they had like a turn a red thing
counterclockwise or turn a blue thing
counterclock or clockwise I don't I
don't remember the specifics but there
was a red and a blue tag
and red is right near the edge of what
bumblebees can see very well
and so when there is no demonstrator
blue tends to be the thing that is
discovered
they both work equally well and the bees
can see the red but they don't find it
first
that said when the demonstrator is
trained on red and blue is discovered in
that Colony red still persists
so
um that that suggests that sort of like
sensory exploitation is not going on
here right like that oh well we can see
this thing but actually you know George
over here has discovered Georgina over
here is discovered
um you know the thing that we can all
see better so let's go there it's like
you know what we're all going to be dead
soon let's just stick with what we know
well
again this is
there's going to be a threshold of
superiority and in fact I didn't read
the paper so I'm just learning about the
the technique but it does seem to me
that you can actually there you've got a
Continuum of difficulty that you could
deploy that would cause you to find the
Threshold at which the changeover was
worth paying and it would be interesting
whether that changeover that threshold
was at a different place at a different
point in the season yes right precisely
um but anyway that is really interesting
and that does sound like such a fun
experiment doesn't it right there are a
lot of boring things you can do and yeah
this is biology graduate school but that
sounds like fun yeah no it it does and
um yeah social learning in in bees
um and just you know reminding us again
that we imagine ourselves uh the only
ones who are capable of the things that
we do on this planet uh at our Peril
it's it's silly right you know there are
a lot of other ways to be and many other
organisms do things better than we do
and uh and many do things worse but also
there are a lot of other ways to arrive
at similar kinds of skills and here you
have an example in bumblebees
ways to be a bee
[Music]
foreign